[Music]
a uh
a guy
goes to
a travis scott concert
oh no another astroworld no not quite we
can move on from that a little bit in
our minds right this sounds like the new
a guy walks into a bar premise
well it's even better than that so this
guy he uh
he decides to throw a bottle
at a group of asian men jesus then he
flips them off and then he starts
hurling racial slurs bro i saw this it's
so satisfying
[ __ ] way yeah
they [ __ ] him up oh i heard about this
he picked the wrong crowd
what the [ __ ] did you think was gonna
happen
what did he say
yeah yeah he's just like saying [ __ ] you
and then
he threw like a red ball
and then he was um taunting them calling
that's like what you get though you know
those guys were chilling too they didn't
do anything for a long time you see the
whole video yeah they were just kept
chucking
and like it was like at least five
minutes later then he got bum rushed
yeah more people gotta get punched in
the face you know what though like
this was pretty normal
you know what this is also not that bad
i was expecting all the guys to [ __ ]
jump this way no they like started
stopping again
they're also probably like on ecstasy so
they like love each other
like it's love bro he was just he gave
up it was just like he wasn't fighting
so like peace love unity respect bro
what the [ __ ] did he think was gonna
happen though you know maybe he kind of
has a thing for that yeah that's weird
that's like the weird thing like you
know man guys that are like that they're
usually too damn drunk to even control
themselves and they they're the kind of
guys that wake up with a broken jaw they
don't even know what they did
yeah
well i hope you know i hope he got beat
up and he learned his lesson that's why
i hope i just want to know what's going
through his head he's like if i could
just throw my ball at these guys
that's what i don't get like
why why like how do these thoughts come
in people's heads like oh let me just
like
like what was throwing [ __ ] like what
was that trying to achieve my boss just
get a good clean shot on this guy you
guys never been so drunk that something
else takes he was also being egged on i
think a lot of people when they're being
egged on they just do dumb ass [ __ ] yeah
yeah
that's true yeah i mean like i remember
being drunk a couple times and like
doing things that
i don't even remember people were like
this is what you did you [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of a pillow you did this and that
that's kind of a brand new like but when
you like black out
when you black out though do you
automatically think of doing things that
would like piss other human beings off
i don't know because like i might i
might black out i might say something
that might offend somebody indirectly
yeah but i wouldn't like
like start doing something that's going
to cause problem approval for peer
approval i've seen people do dumb [ __ ]
like that like maybe this guy's like got
a piece of douche in them you know
sure
so i like kind of sleepwalk kind of
right we're like i'll fall asleep and
then she's like trying to help me get up
off the couch so that i don't like hurt
my back or neck or some [ __ ] i can go to
bed with her right but i'll be like
i'm not even tired [ __ ] you and all this
[ __ ] you're all mean to her yeah she
says i'm mean as [ __ ] and then i'll i'll
just be like tired [ __ ] off yeah and
i'll tell her to [ __ ] off and then i
start laughing at like whatever she's
saying and then i think that she's
basically the stupidest [ __ ] i've
ever encountered and i'm just like yeah
whatever [ __ ] off like little [ __ ]
noob i bet you've never heard of luna
before you [ __ ] loser [ __ ] trash
ass noobs stay wrecked you [ __ ] noobs
some safe moon good luck finding a
husband
so no but she says i do this like you
know when she's trying to wake me up and
then so now
she's just like man let this
[ __ ] sleep down here
because like wake steve i'm very nice to
her but it's dream steve i'm just like
[ __ ] off you [ __ ] [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here
damn i get it though i'll go down like
that needles do the same thing i'll like
say something maybe [ __ ] should be
like what did you drink today oh then
i'll be like oh really it's a drink
thing yeah
and now i'll be like
i guess i was just drinking tequila
she's like
all right
well you're awake though yeah i'm awake
oh see i'm talking about i'm like past
the [ __ ] out asleep i fall asleep on the
couch yeah it makes you way worse yeah
yeah bro i'm not even the same guy will
you guys when you guys say you guys get
like blackout drunk or like close to
that what are your tendencies from like
your friends that what they tell you
about like how drunk you get i can't
even the last time i got blackout drunk
was 2006
and i went to uh a ucb party i've talked
about before was the absence of absence
night after that [ __ ] that i'll never
get blackout drunk again do you act
different with different types of liquor
absolutely
for sure i don't really drink
it's i think think about like uh you
ever smoke weed yeah think about like
the idea think about the idea of weed
the idea of smoking weed sometimes
people smoke like an indica for like a
body hard to chill out or to like eat or
insomnia and then other people might
smoke like a sativa for like a head high
to focus to not have like 80d or
whatever right alcohol can work with
similar properties maybe it's not so
like direct and like you know i want
this experience but like for example if
i drink crown where i want to get drunk
off it i got pissed i don't know why
really you get pissed fist like this all
the time just like constantly thinking
like don't bring that here i'm
aggressive or like if i drink
like tequila right it's not as much of a
depressant as like whiskey so tequila
usually like you [ __ ] daytime drink
level up do whatever you got to do feel
like a god what about absence
is just [ __ ] tastes like black
licorice and then you black out wow i've
been blacked out once from captain
morgan
and i get i ate half a half of loaf of
bread
and then woke up like four hours later
and when i was trying to throw up there
was no liquid it was just bread oh my
god but i didn't do anything stupid i
like had a cut on my finger and then
that and ever since then i don't drink
kind of a legend though yeah yeah keep
right away from this guy yeah
wait what was that what was that [ __ ] up
no are you good
i'm sorry i'm sorry he does that to
everybody though it's his thing oh
that's your thing why is it so
rewarding to watch instant karma [ __ ]
yeah it is especially drunk people when
drunk people are just like acting like a
[ __ ] fool and then they get [ __ ] up
when you're driving guy cuts you off
then he blasts forward he goes like 100
miles an hour then a cop pulls him over
it's like i could come yeah
i almost do yeah yeah i almost do it it
rarely happens though i've only had that
happen like one time my entire life
i've seen that once when i was driving
back here from arizona there was this
guy zooming through and like throwing up
gang signs out the window and then we
got up for a little further and he was
pulled over by the cops out of his car
still throwing ganks
dude
he's like hey officer what did i do i'm
literally just representing this one i'm
just representing you i'm representing
there's a really popular uh video uh
online that old guy who's like flipping
somebody off got a dude crushing the
street yeah crosstalk
so [ __ ] sad it's so pissed that's
sweet but he walks straight into the
[ __ ] pole
good never walked into a pool before
absolutely yeah i don't remember the
last time i did but i've done it mine
was in uh third grade
i was wow what a [ __ ] loser dude i
remember because i got sent home early
from school i remember i was running and
they had like this big ramada and there
was the girl that i liked was like
playing with their friends the worst
when the girl that you like is watching
this [ __ ] it was like i just remember
running and then all of a sudden like
the like the outdoor lady was like in
front of me she's like are you okay and
i was like i think so i don't even know
what happened and then i had the biggest
lump out of my head and i ran straight
into a corner of a pole
and they sent me home i had to put ice
on it i had a concussion it was it was a
whole thing that's a damn
i saw a kid [ __ ] hit a parked car
with a bicycle fell down everyone's like
oh no and we all ran up are you okay and
he gone on his bike he goes just leave
me alone
[Laughter]
to the sunset where's the bullying why
bullying him we were just like are you
okay dude
don't bully him that is fine too yes
that's him
that's him dude he got a mag of hat and
there you get the magazine
and he hasn't said he gets more meds
cute marines he's mad at you
i didn't do anything you [ __ ]
you have a dumb yelling in the first
place because the dude didn't stop
perfectly on the line it looked like he
was though it did yeah sometimes you
it's la right you stop a little bit over
the line and then people walking around
like oh really
so you just added like three steps to my
step counter you [ __ ] [ __ ] like
whatever dude that dude's probably got
his his wife's dog you know what i mean
it's always like a cute little
pomeranian or something that they're
walking
this guy has had to have seen this video
yeah dude the best part though i hope he
has he's like that's not me the best
part is the fake out like he's gonna
punch your car but he's like six feet
away from him if you were outside
oh my god
georgia the jungle
oh
oh i beat your [ __ ] out of your car
you're so lucky right now oh my god
you're so lucky he's like you're like i
can't see straight right now [ __ ]
like the dog's all laughing
i've showed you guys gross ride the web
right ghost ride the whip okay this is
my favorite one of my favorite videos of
all time the instant karma one yeah this
is instant caramel one it's like these
guys were like dude we are [ __ ]
killing it at life right so we're doing
this cool stunt oh this is class classic
yeah they're they're going way too fast
oh
oh [ __ ] maybe i should go spread the
whip huh oh
[ __ ]
this dude is ghost riding the whip at
like 50 miles an hour but imagine you're
this cat right and you're like dude i
literally i'm ghost riding through up so
[ __ ] hard right now life is
incredible and you're like holy [ __ ]
maybe i shouldn't be ghost riding the
whip
he was so hyped
he was so high holy [ __ ] dude yeah
normally they're going like five miles
an hour no this guy's gone
that is a pretty funny reaction when
people are really hyped to do some wild
[ __ ] and then as soon as they start to
do it they get cold feet and they're
like oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] the lack of
commitment there's one video that's
going around recently whereas it's it's
a guy in a boat and there's a giant like
grouper fish oh i know she's talking
about it but it's big as [ __ ] and he's
like oh this is for the gram oh this is
the gram yeah yeah yeah and he gets he
tries to get in the water and he's
supposed to hang on to the fish and as
he hangs on to the fish the fish starts
going crazy and it's big as [ __ ] and
he's like flipping out and it flips
under him and it's a wilder [ __ ] but you
see the reaction of him being like yeah
yeah let's do it and then he gets in
he's like kind of scared and he's like
oh i don't want to do it i don't want to
do it he has second yeah second one oh
my god cause the fish is literally it's
like it's his biggest alley that [ __ ]
it's like everybody who did the [ __ ]
crate challenge
oh yeah man every single guy did a great
job but watching them fall was one of
the funniest things ever it felt so like
it takes so long i think there's still
people for with like adverse injuries
from that did somebody die somebody died
the lady died for me
what a [ __ ] whack way to go man
that's how you die from doing a [ __ ]
crate challenge
every year at least she did something
challenging that's true she challenged
herself do you think anybody died from
the ice bucket challenge
i don't remember that probably when they
when they did the buckets and it fell
and hit it i think i heard one story
like that really yeah
they're neck and chest somebody died
from the ice bucket challenge
people died from the cinnamon challenge
the cinnamon would go in their [ __ ]
lungs and [ __ ] there was one death from
the ice bucket challenge
that's always when the challenges stop
it's like somebody dies okay i think we
should move on to the next death defying
challenge i've never seen the instant
karma video it's like the two ladies on
the news and they're like squishing
grapes yes oh yeah she's like stop and
then she tries to squish a little bit
more and then trips and she's like oh oh
oh my god
the very first the best one they're on
tv
yo the fact that all of us know that
yeah it's so good except for no i've
seen this one yeah yeah yeah i've seen
this one this is a classic it is a
classic this is like ebon's world cup
download that whole video is that still
around e-bombs it is as a social media
platform yeah
wins an overnight stay but it's not the
only thing you can do the measuring cups
are down below right measuring cups are
down below all right
and if you if you win you get to stay a
having chat tours and tasting vineyard
chores
come on what is going to happen
it's a lot of fun as soon as they say
promo yeah
and the music's still playing this part
oh dear i think
dude the
if not for the setup the punchline would
be so much worse yeah the setup of them
just doing the casual news [ __ ] is the
best part
they have to go back and then they come
back to oh that looks like it hurts i
know he's like i think she's actually
hers like yeah she literally just ate
her pubic bone that cracked there she
felt
face first like physical assessment
i wish they'd come back to them going
they're not sure they're like oh i think
she's actually let's cut back
oh yeah yeah
you